[Music]
good morning everybody it is my great
pleasure to welcome Joanna Bryson to
Microsoft Research today for her to give
her talk and she's gonna be spending the
day here talking to a bunch of us she is
an Associated associate professor at the
University of birth and she is a
transdisciplinary researcher focusing on
many different problems meeting many
problems that are very interesting to us
at the intersection of AI psychology
autonomy ethics of robotics and human
and human cooperation collaboration so
I'll welcome her to talk about her
fascinating research and if you have
questions during the talk please free to
ask thank you
all right well thanks oh yeah I'm not
using that microphone okay thanks for
having me here I have its usual a lot of
slides so I'll just get into it please
do ask but thanks very much everybody
involved in inviting me originally Jamie
but it's become a very team effort yeah
you may think it's weird that I'm
talking about the European Union but I'm
just taking it as another interesting
political entity and they had these very
specific goals which are human dignity
and flourishing and I don't know about
you when I first heard about these goals
it's not like you know like you know
vaporware right like what does that even
mean right but I've come to realize that
well yeah it's sort of what it means is
that everybody needs at least enough
stability in their lives so that they
can plan that so that they can build a
business so they can decide whether to
have a family not everybody needs a
family but that you can have these kinds
of things as options right so there's
something that we need in order to
flourish and we've been doing a pretty
good job of flourishing do I get a a
laser I could just point so this is the
log scale
population in millions of humans and
that started from 10,000 true there's a
build so I need a does anyone have the
laser that they're carrying around well
here it is
I found one yeah so yeah so what
happened 10,000 years ago up until 10
thousand years ago we were being out
competed by monkeys monkeys evolved more
recently the humans there were more
macaque than hominids and then all of a
sudden we got writing agriculture
urbanization and doctrinal religion as
an AI person I'd like to think the
writing is the key thing but I like to
talk about writing is the first AI
because there's off-board memory it
allowed us to innovate and then all of a
sudden we get this amazing so we're
flourishing right as we know sometimes
you might also think about that's an
exponential exponential that's super
intelligence right and as we've all
heard my my fellow immigrant colleague
in the UK there's sometimes
unanticipated sub-goals of super
intelligence and one is that we're
wiping out all the other large animals
you can see that even before that ten
thousand years ago when when humans got
to continent it was sometimes bad news
but actually some of that is because I
build there was actually another bit of
global warming right then so that we
maybe the reason we were going moving so
much was because there was reasons to go
and that was hard but look at this
there's actually more biomass now
especially since the Industrial
Revolution we're actually taking energy
out of the ground and out of the sky and
things and creating more biomass but
we're converting it entirely into people
and livestock all right and so this is
the other another unanticipated sub goal
is the green boxes there and this is
from a few years ago are all the wild
animals there left right wild mammals
okay of course another unanticipated sub
goal is that we have started helping
produce even more climate change and
that kind of thing brings all kinds of
things we don't really necessarily want
all right I've got to say it all of that
is not only because of climate there's
there's lots of things that drive that
change and one of the things is the
economy so sometimes we have these
periods with very high inequality and
that tends to correlate with very high
political polarization or identity
politics
so pairs of very great volatility so
this has rolled more one does anyone
want to guess why we have numbers going
back to World War one there was this
crazy thing where we outlawed alcohol
and we in when we alcohol outlawed
alcohol we needed more tax so we created
income tax so since the innovation of
income to actually know what proportion
of wealth has gone to the top one
percent and we can see that that
correlates pretty well with the amount
of political polarization and this is
measured by whether or not the two
houses of Congress but for both houses
of Congress the two parties are both
their names are on bills okay so that's
a particular measure due to Nolan
McCarthy and actually his PhD
supervisors he's now a professor at
Princeton so anyway these are pretty
well correlated and there's some
interesting things going on there but we
in the 30s in both the US and the UK we
managed to get our act together and and
and reduce both inequality and the
polarization and we kept it down until
about nineteen seventy eight and then
we've started launching up again on both
of those measures I think I think this
is his field but I think that part of
the reason there's more of a gap here
than there is because this is measuring
income inequality but probably wealth
inequality is what does the driving
alright so so we don't have income for a
longer time but we do have polarization
since since the Civil War and more
broadly we can look at people believe
they have inequality I don't know if I
believe the y-axis here and that you can
really match it up this way
they're famously there are some papers
here idle claiming that you have to have
war and mayhem or else you don't get
reductions of inequality but I think
that things like this matters that shift
in the in the and and this was between
wars when we did that so I think we can
do things with policy to reduce
inequality and polarization as well so
yeah why why do we care one reason we
care and this has just come out in the
last year it's been a big question we
know there's a correlation what the
causation is has been a big question one
of the things we know is that extreme
position
and politicians are driven by extreme
positions in major single donors and so
one of the things that inequality does
is increase this number of people who
can be such major single donors right
because there's relatively few people
with large amounts of money and this has
been changing just spectacularly in the
last in the last couple decades all
right so you've probably wondered by
this point is she gonna talk about AI or
not and so mostly I've been talking
about right now so far sort of studying
the the groundwork with the impediment
to a stable society part and now I'm not
going to talk about AI I'm just going to
talk about intelligence all right so I
realized this is Microsoft Research I
don't mean to pander but this is a slide
I already had and I was lazy but also I
think it's interesting to see that you
can pitch it this way so I like to
remind people that intelligence is
relying on computation in that math a
lot of people just assume that
intelligence can be spontaneous it's
absolutely true that AI is necessarily
going to be unbiased and neutral because
in their mistaking algorithms for math
and math or computation all right so
computation is a physical process it's a
transformation of information right any
physical process takes time energy in
space right we all know this is sort of
the Patrick Winston but not that there's
anything wrong with that
version of AI but finding the right
thing to do at the right time which is a
fundamental problem of intelligence is a
form of search and the cost of search is
the number of options rates the number
of acts right and so that's why you know
again you guys know this that means that
if you have a robot that can do a
hundred things and it gets a two stuck
plan there's 10,000 possible plans
already but believe me you talked about
this you give the slide to politicians
even people are pretty well-informed and
they're stunned right the whole thing
about 35 Move games of chess not moving
the the rook back and forth right people
don't understand this all right so you
guys being at Microsoft are probably
thinking hasn't she heard about the
cloud yet right the the concurrency can
save on real time but the energy require
it you know it obviously you have the
time you double the amount of space
required and the energy requirements are
constant weirdly people aren't even
tight
about what's going on with quantum write
that again it's like gonna be this magic
thing it's gonna solve this stuff it
does seem to save on space once for some
subset of problems you can solve things
in a single computer but so far it looks
like the energy is more than the space
lost although there's not enough good
work done in this this is my kid my
personal captive quantum physicists but
I've given this talk a lot of places and
nobody's told me I'm wrong about this
Hey but basically nobody's doing math on
the energy problems with quantum so yes
emissions is not actually a real threat
that's not the problem and you and
literally this again I probably don't
need to tell anyone in this room but I
have been in DC where people we're
talking about what if one country finds
the machine learning algorithm and
suddenly knows all the things right so
you know and then that somehow there'd
be no way to get cover from that ok
natural intelligence is not general
again I get I wrote the slide talk
yesterday nobody said this to me this
money nobody has so far and the three
people I've talked to you has mentioned
AGI but anyway I'll mention it right
early in psychology we thought that any
stimulus could provoke any response we
were wrong all right it turns out
pigeons can learn to pack for food and
to flap their wings to avoid shock and
incidentally not every pigeon can learn
this most pigeons don't Peck that much
it's actually the genius pigeons that
we're used for all those experiments you
see and people tell you oh pigeons right
ok but anyway pigeons can learn to peck
for food they cannot learn to peck in
order to avoid Shaq or to flap their
wings for food that doesn't make sense
if you're a pigeon those kinds of things
are stuff you would never need to know
so those connectivity is not there your
brain doesn't provide you the bias to do
that kind of learning all right so um
yeah so yeah this is what this is the
advantage of science there were some
other sources of knowledge ok now that
we understand kalma torques this is one
of the big questions I had it's an
undergraduate why is it that the brain
given that there's evolution and
everything why isn't the brain settle
down on one architecture right why
haven't we figured out the best way to
represent information why is there
different connectivity in different
parts of the brain well different parts
of the brain are solving different
problems so
different after most solutions these
different problems and so of course
you're gonna get different connectivity
and different representations and things
you nobody really when you think about
hard expects that you know that the
whole brain is going like one giant
retina right I mean come on it's just
doing different stuff all right
so that also explains why some level of
bias especially even prejudice is a
necessary part of AI and again I I think
you guys know about this work but I
don't know how many people know about my
science paper the one about the word
embeddings have have prejudice okay how
many people know about your guys paper
that came out well it hit our car at the
same time but was was but when two nips
right okay so that was for those of you
don't know there's actually that that
was entirely an overlapping group but
listen everyone all right so I will do
this a little bit so if you just use
word embeddings which is basically a
giant vector I'm going to show you a
picture later so you basically just sit
around and count whether words how words
could occur next to each other you
recover the things that scientists call
implicit biases all right so we took
every single study we could find this is
because the first author in the was
Princeton postdoc and the final author
was up for tenure this year for instance
every single paper that had the implicit
association test in it and used it used
words and used them on the general
population because we were using the web
and we couldn't tell which who'd written
what part of the web so we it could only
use general population results but we
matched every single one of them right
so this for example is showing you have
a bunch of women's names representing
women and men's names representing men
and family words representing the
domestic sphere and career words
representing the corporate sphere and
then you find if the world was a
perfectly fair pit place people should
be able to if you give them the task of
matching words up they should be just as
fast at matching up women to career and
men to to family as the other way around
but in fact they're much faster at doing
women to career to family in men to
career and so this is the the
them being faster like regular people
and D is a measurement in terms of
standard deviation because we don't have
a theory of how long it should take but
we do we just look and say are these two
things different so we see the normal
distribution we say how far apart of
those two normal distributions and there
these are giant this is huge when people
say like oh you know this isn't a real
effect what are they talking about hey
this is one of the biggest effects in
psychology the implicit association test
and people are saying it's fake news
right because it doesn't correlate
perfectly with explicit prejudice and I
think that's because people don't know
the difference between implicit and
explicit memory anymore which we got got
taught if your oldest I am in college
anyway so the the point is that they
were saying this and I still get people
who hammer me when I give that talk I
didn't think I needed to give that talk
here saying don't you know that you
can't trust psychology look totally
different method doing word counting
large corpus linguistics the same kind
of stuff latent semantic analysis the
way that we do search right for webpages
and we were able to replicate well
replicate is not quite the right word
also find evidence of bias in the words
okay and the headlines all said AI is
prejudice and the good headlines said
and it's because of us but that wasn't
really the finding the real finding was
that words are word use what we pass on
to other people as well as to machines
contains the image not only of our of
our of our implicit biases but actually
and this is something completely down to
the that final thought I made and Arvind
Arianna
he said I want to see what happens with
something that's real okay so the the
y-axis here is the same awful prejudiced
word embeddings that gave us that that
women are closer to the domestic sphere
than to the to the work sphere so
there's exact same things but then we
went out and looked at the 2015 US Labor
Statistics which unfortunately weren't
all single terms and this only works for
single terms so we have to just throw
away the adjectives so that's why
there's some of the noise but 90%
correlation again if you're in
psychology that's a huge deal ninety
cent percent correlation in predicting
like how male or female
word was like this is programmer
unfortunately when I was a programmer we
were at like 13 percent of the
population women were and and this is
the 80s and it went up but peaked around
18 or 19 percent it's crashed it's like
four or five percent it's just appalling
and I don't know why if there's lots of
women in the audience programming is fun
I love programming I don't know what's
happened anyway
so so yeah and this is like being a
nurse or something up here right and and
and fortunately being a doctor is over
here somewhere but anyway I learned a
lot last summer but the point is that
that our implicit biases turn out to
reflect the current reality in some
cases not all of them right and that's
sort of interesting it's it's kind of
cool because that going back to the
implicit explicit divide that means that
we can explicitly decide oh we want to
employ women we think it's a good it's
good for women to be able to have jobs
and we can try to shift to something new
but the implicit biases seem to be
bootstrapping off of observed reality or
historic reality or something so yeah go
ahead and ask me more questions but
anyway that wasn't going to be the point
of this talk sorry so the point is that
when you're a member of a cognitive
species then it makes sense for you to
exploit the concurrent computation that
others are doing and again I didn't have
time I put way too many slides into this
but I have a beautiful video ask me if
you want in Q&A of Tauruses learning
from each other right and they're not
very smart these tortoises are not smart
but when they see a tortoise solve a
problem they solve the problem - alright
it's a problem they couldn't solve for a
month all right so so it just makes
sense this is a way to think about what
culture is it's it's the exploitation of
computation has already been done okay
so we can do this explicitly with
students and apprentices
I just mentioned you can have implicit
social learning even it's really stupid
things like reptiles and fish right and
I'm sorry you didn't put a reference in
there just ask me for the references if
you want and one of the things that's
going on is we have implicit sensitivity
to social examples and I think that's
what's going on with the overactive
anthropomorphism of AI okay so now I'll
come down and start actually talking
about artificial intelligence all right
I think yeah not quite almost just
before AI I was asked to give a keynote
at a robo fill which you probably won't
have heard of it but it's actually a
fairly big meeting of philosophers and
people working on social robots so
things that are suppose to look like
people and participate in human society
okay and this was like the fourth or
fifth time that it's met I think it's a
biannual but what's the first time they
met in Vienna and it's the first time
they invited more general scientists to
it and they titled it this year politics
power in the public space okay speaking
of public spaces this is a statue by a
Seward Johnson and he he produced a
whole lot of statues in the 70s and put
them into public spaces and in the 70s
that was getting a little dicey in some
of these public spaces and it turned out
that if you put something looked like a
person into a public space
you made that space safer people felt
more like there was another person
around all right
this is a statue okay and and it's not
about and you a lot of philosophers had
this huge thing about intuition like you
can tell that a robot is a person you
can tell that and how could you be
denying something you know denying
rights to something that you can feel is
definitely a personal you feel the
statue as a person - okay and you can
show that you feel that because it
alters your behavior all right so the
yeah so over-scaled statues fascinate
yet diminish us that's something as soon
as Johnson actually said so he got bored
of making humans scale once he started
taking pieces of art and then blowing
them up it's really cool those are my
parents hanging out at the at the
statutes it's a place in New Jersey
called grounds for sculpture okay so
yeah yeah there's a concept from
psychology again just being this remote
and supernormal stimulus that if you
have something that you evolved to
attend to and then you're never going to
in evolutionary history if it's
something that was a greater example of
that you can actually over respond to it
and your biology doesn't shut you down
from doing that arguably we've been
doing things like this for a long time
right okay so so what happens with AI
right I was on this is how I got into AI
ethics so I have a couple degrees in
psychology but I also have a couple
degrees in AI and when I started my PhD
I was on this project that was I mean
this robot at the time that I was on it
at the time this picture was taken did
not work this is basically a sculpture
made out of motors okay but it turned
out there was all these processors that
were supposed to be its brain and it
turned out they weren't properly
grounded so anyways that the whole time
I was on the project it didn't work and
yet people would walk by and say it'd be
unethical to unplug that and they were
proud to know that they had the certain
knowledge to be honest gotta unplug this
thing all right a-and and if they they
generalize from feminism and the civil
rights movement they found out that the
most unlikeliest things turn out to be
people right and that they could just
say oh yeah well you know obviously if a
woman could be a person then this is -
right yeah so anyway yeah and and
there's something really strange going
on here they really really get angry if
you say that this is not a person that
they say that we have a right to fall in
love with these things we have a right
to have our best friends that we can buy
that we can buy and sell citizens right
so I think this is sort of both sick and
dangerous and I say that as somebody who
seriously what thought she was going to
dedicate an entire PhD to making this
into a child alright so I realized I get
it I've been there but you can read some
of the papers about this Kathleen
Richardson in particular talks about
this in the feminist context but yeah so
this was me back then if you're young
like that now beware but but that robot
on the left on the road on the right
didn't work at the time it did
eventually work but one of them left
already worked nobody ever said like a
vehicle unplug the insect robots even
though they actually worked they were
smarter in some sense
right so yeah unethical Dan plug cog and
my supervisor at that time again I
didn't finish with him guess I got
called conservative for saying robots
might not take over people were
absolutely certain that robots are going
to take over right and this was not
again random people this was people on a
panel he was on of other scientists and
philosophers and and and and the AI
builders okay so because of all this I
wrote with the only philosopher I knew
at the time we wrote this in 1996 it
took us forever to get it into the
crappiest possible workshop and then
finally we did a rewrite and reboot and
put it into each guy more recently but
this is the 1998 text all right we
believe exaggerated fears live in hopes
for AI are symptomatic of a larger
problem a giant confusion about the
nature of humanity and the role of
ethics and society our thesis is that
these exaggerated fears are false
concerns which can distract us from the
real dangers of AI technologies often I
get cast as somebody who's like you know
saying oh there's nothing to worry about
what they I I know you're worrying about
the wrong things or they I write the
real dangers are no different though
from the other those of other artifacts
the potential for misuse either through
carelessness or malevolence by the
people who control them all right so
this is a slide that I wrote my start
giving talks because of the things
people were saying about my my or our
bias paper that came out right so a lot
of people said oh look this is terrible
because society is is bad therefore AI
is going to be bad so yes you can have
biases in this in this case and I don't
like to use bias this way but anyway
they are absorbed automatically by
machine learning from ordinary culture
that's true that's one source of them
there's also like accidental bias that's
being introduced through ignorance by
you know for example the Kate Crawford
kind of insufficiently diverse a
development team yes that's also a
problem but the main thing that hack
worried about is that she could
deliberately introduce bias somebody
could say hey I've been elected only by
the people from the east coast of you
know the east side of town let's figure
out a way to save money and let's just
take it on the west side because they
weren't voting for me anyway so we don't
need to worry
that right he can you can come and do
that and if you forget that AI is
something somebody built then nobody is
gonna guess nobody's gonna notice right
and nobody was talking about this they
were all sitting there that in the New
York Times talking about you know the
silicon valley's problem with with lack
of diversity which is an issue but it's
not the issue okay it's an issue okay
yeah anyway back to what I was saying
yeah this was the most focus I had but
another of magnitude ever and anthem
Loveland AI book has come out since then
but yeah malevolence right and level
it's deliberate right so anyway ethical
instincts and ethics itself we claimed
was rooted in identity right and that's
something a lot of people said and we
humans mistakenly place language
mathematics and reason is the car of
humanity because it discriminates us
from animals and then we can use them
and stuff right and we thought back in
1996 as I said what we wrote this that
once we have empirical experience of AI
this confusion is probably going to go
away at least and we were talking about
like oh how can we get children the
experience of building AI young so they
can be smarter about this right and
they're maybe even we've started forming
our human ethics Supes so the sound is
not coming in oh I know
so this is just an undergraduate funding
of course and intelligent control and
cognitive systems but they didn't
develop these robots to be social they
had just been doing room but listen to
them
I don't know I know if you're picking
it's up to me it's pretty clear to me
that these guys are identifying with the
robots they felt they are projecting
themselves into this space and it's as
if they were there that they're falling
over they're saying these things they're
they're seeing themselves in their
robots they're running around like I I
was talking the same types of thing
those robots were built by them
individually for their projects and then
we had this thing called the beauty
competition at the end of the year to
decide which robots don't have to be
dismantled but rather can be used to
attract freshmen to University of Bath
and to live for another year and the
beauty competition of space time we
bring three naive people who don't know
anything about AI one year we use the
theory of computation people grouped two
to look at the robots and see which one
just looks most intelligent from the
outside okay so anyway
the point is that that so the students
are seeing their robots do something
they've never done before which is
interact with other robots and they
project themselves into it and we get
this final year student at a leading
computer science undergraduate in
Britain who has built and programmed the
robot themselves talking about loving us
robot okay so the okay yeah I'm sure you
can make some kindest Association here I
think that at least for developers that
we can have like the movie actor
dissociation but it's not clear to me in
fact you know anyone who is an actor
knows that not everybody can make the
movie actor movie character actor
dissociation anyway right and it's not
clear what's happening to people when we
put robots out there that they're able
to tell that there's this this narrative
that we like to play and then there's
the reality of the robot yes it's just
AI know like I've done a study of
programmers debugging distributed
systems and they say things like the
server says this and then the client
says that right so it's not I don't know
that it's that they're
anthropomorphizing it so much is just
it's a useful vocabulary like that's
just a useful metaphor for describing
the technology that's certainly true and
that's and that's actually a really
difficult problem
especially if you start becoming known
for this stuff
yeah I have to go back through my proofs
and make sure that I haven't done that
all the time because of course it was
easier to say oh the car wants to do
this or whatever so that is ordinary
language you're right but when it
becomes something that an awful lot of
ordinary culture has told people really
is a person then I think it starts to
become confusing and so that's why I do
go back to my proofs and try to make
that that change but but yeah I remember
when we used to say like a multi-agent
systems is going to be a new way to do
software engineering because it helps
people think better about especially in
you know in proactive context real-time
proactive context the responsibilities
of the different parts this isn't this
isn't of the of the system if they can
use social reasoning on those different
aspects and there's all this nice
anthropology showing that we're better
at reasoning about humans than about you
know abstractions so anyway I think this
is the way I currently think what's
going on so I sort of mentioned this
before intelligence is doing the right
thing at the right time and artificial
intelligence the only difference between
it and natural is that it's an artifact
it was deliberately made right so agents
are just a vector of change we don't
care about agency what we care about is
moral agents okay the moral agent is the
thing that a society holds responsible
for their actions now a lot of people
think when you get into ethics that
there there is some absolute ethics that
we're all converging towards that
somebody has written down a set of rules
and carved in stone and we just need to
figure it out but I can give you very
clear examples of moral agency being
different between societies which is
that what age is a child responsible for
their own actions okay massive
disagreement about a fundamental
question right between between cultures
even when how old do you need to be to
say that you want to be married or to
consent to sex right this is something
that we spend a lot of time trying to
figure out so moral agency is something
that it's such a society works out for
itself and well patients see similarly
it's the other side is what are the
things we feel respond
before now the interesting thing is that
these together are moral subjects and if
you look at for example Roman law they
sort of say oh you're only a moral payor
legal patient if you're a legal agent
right the law is about us but that's the
opposite of what we have psycho
psychological intuitions so people feel
that that there's more patience e where
there's less agency so we we are
supposed to be helping babies you know
and a lot of people don't feel obliged
to you know adults that have addiction
problems or whatever they're like hey
come on they're an adult they should
take care of it themselves so so right
so that's the way that's these are the
definitions just so we have a clearer
conversation about what the actual
problems are okay and now this is all
just true this is a weird thing that
people hate okay so my claim is that
ethics is the set of behaviors that
creates and sustains a society right
including by defining its identity and
that's why we get hung up and some of
the things like okay the British don't
eat horses right they don't and the
people in Eastern Europe they do but
it's a big deal yeah this is not your
main point but do you think of either
illusion is there intelligence sorry
visual illusions yeah well I think it's
a part of our entire yes but let's let's
that's an interesting question but it's
not directly in the current narratives
let's say were freaking eh okay all
right so um so ethics is something that
a society develops to stabilize itself
and there are things that that will be
there will be this includes general
principles right like you know murder
and theft and things like that tend to
destabilize a society any society so
societies will tend to converge on those
kinds of rules but then as I said one of
the things that helps you keep your
society together is by maintaining this
identity deciding who is a part of your
society that is actually one of the
things by which uses you society defends
itself I mean you could think of as the
original part of governance is that the
main the main thing that governance does
its allocate resources to create
defining an identity for a group right
you to build to build some kind of
defenses around the village or something
right that's that's sort of the
redistribution and security are the sort
of central things that are defining a
society so that can function particular
ways um what I'm claiming here is that
this that that all the behaviors are
that by which we maintain the society
and just calling those ethics so it's
the extent that you need behavior and
this is kind of a weird definition like
this is an eccentric mantra
communicating now this is not what
you're going to find the dictionary
right but but so to the extent that you
need behavior to have a society do you
need other things is that sufficient
while you need the individuals right but
but the ethics so there has to be a
society society it's made of something
certain States Society or two societies
or right that's a really interesting
question
so that so to some extent there's sub
societies within that and then there's a
super society which has which has
presumably some part of the intersection
that and some other rules too including
just like you know like being enforced
by the by the state powers so yeah so
okay because this definition is kind of
seeking for something more like static
yeah no no it's not actually
yeah change is the big issue and I don't
want to go into it in great detail but
the whole reason that I was studying
this definition up which I don't
actually go into that much in the rest
of the talk so I'll go ahead and say
this here it's because given the ethics
is itself an artifact and the AI is
definitionally an artifact
there's no fact of the matter of where
we stick a eye into society that's not a
scientifically discoverable fact it's
rather something that we need to be
optimizing so this comes into where
you're in my research is similar that we
keep doing things like iteratively
improving that solution so the whole
reason I'm saying this is to get it to
people because while you think that
ethics is a static target that
moving towards that you're just
perfecting and I believe me you can get
philosophers professional philosophers
they're really angry about this stuff
that will get up and say something like
we now know better than people knew you
know the people knew in the 1940s or
whatever you know and it's like I don't
think we know we know some things better
we are I do I'm not one of these people
is a complete cultural relativist I do
believe that we are aggregating more
information but I wouldn't say that we
have the perfect ethics right or that
that's even definable because it depends
on the particular society and the
societies have to be agile and enable to
deal with change right so I would expect
it to change so that's not what I'm
going towards in fact that's why I'm
trying to defend against okay well we'll
come to somewhere of that so right again
this is not the kinds of things I think
you guys are concerned about I'll go
ahead and leave the slide in when I say
that that that AI is not necessarily
that the AI is placed in ethics you know
it doesn't have to be a moral agent and
moral patient what I'm trying to say is
that well what I just said that we don't
have to take it as something we have to
give that kind of consideration that
doesn't mean that we can't take moral
action all right so what is moral
actions but if you have a behavioral
context therefore it's more than one
possible action and the individual well
in first and first of all the society
believes that someone of those actions
is more socially beneficial and the
individual is able to recognize that all
right then in that case I would call
that a moral action right that if you
but when you have to make this decision
whether you can make a more or less
moral which is more or less socially
essential into action and I've
deliberately again set this up in a way
to make it totally easy to build and and
you can talk about it in things like
monkeys so monkeys will punish other
monkeys that aren't doing the right
thing that don't give food calls or
apparently they'll even are like who get
a whole troop barking at a dominant
monkey that's being too abusive of its
position of power and beating up another
monkey too much right so you can talk
about that kind of action in monkeys it
with a pet if you come home the
food in the middle of the rug and you
think the diagnose by the nurse and you
you shout at the dog right and the doc I
probably thinks you knew better than to
come home at 12:00 at night okay and
that's why i pooed there right so
they're both sanctioning each other
right but but nobody outside of your
household is going to consider the dog
to be immoral illegal agent or whatever
right but you're acting like within the
society of your family that you thought
the diag new what its options were and
that it chose the wrong one okay so we
can we can I'm not saying that a I has
to be a moral when I say that we don't
need to make AI out to be moral agents
or moral patients okay right yeah so
yeah monkeys children pets linen slaves
and robots can't honestly select moral
actions without being held to be moral
bi or legal agents by their wider
society I'm not saying I support all
those solutions I'm not saying that I
think it's a good idea to consider some
people to not be responsible or or or to
own their own actions or property but
I'm saying that those are the kinds of
decisions societies have previously made
and I think it's very important to
realize that when we talk about human
justice it's not about it like maintain
some kind of balance it's a lot of it's
about dissuasion and so one of the
things that I'm going here with this set
of things that I'm realizing I've put
too many interesting talks together and
not drawing quite enough threads but
where I'm going with this is it doesn't
make sense for the AI to be set up as a
legal as a legal agent as a as a as a
legal person because we're not going to
be able to sanction it so we can still
have it taking legal actions but not be
the legal agent all right and yeah so
monkeys and pets are easily dissuaded oh
by things like social isolation you know
being isolated is torture for a social
social animal like fish that like to
school they die of stress when you take
them to an isolated situation and it is
torture for humans right so my case and
pets are are dissuaded by the kinds of
things we do they may not care if they
lose their money but they care about
being isolated from their families AI
and shell companies
you can make it care about money and and
things like that but they aren't
dissuade Abell hate the whole point of
the shell company is that the people who
are taking the fall are not the ones who
mind right that you've set something up
that can loot they can go bankrupt and
nobody actually cares alright so only
makes sense for a company to be a legal
person if someone cares that that
company goes bankrupt right I mean the
person who's that if it's the people who
are making the executive decisions that
company cares care if it goes bankrupt
right and so AI is the ultimate shell
company and that's what I'm trying to
defend part against in this slide and
there's a if if that was a little too
fast and loose you could go into this
really nice formal paper by these two
guys our law professors this is just
alphabetical he did most of the good
decisions he hated mostly good writing
but this came out last year all right so
my conjecture here is that none of
things like consciousness language and
ethics are the things that mandate moral
subjectivity that we need to worry about
AI as being a moral agent and moral
patient looks like an attorney on the
stand on this okay so the there for
millions of years intelligence
consciousness agency language morality
and divinity have all been at least seen
as correlated but as we all know
correlations not equal the causation and
I it drives me crazy when people sit
here and worry about when is AI going to
become conscious we can build it to
express the different definitions we
have of consciousness that doesn't
change its moral status right so for
example one of the things that makes a
human incredibly valuable is the fact
that they're not replaceable you can't
if once someone is dead they're just
gone right AI you can back up right so
even if you had something it was exactly
like a person if you decided to have one
copy of it then you don't have the same
kinds of about the complications towards
it right all right so yeah a substantial
objective so this is a complain about
philosophers who confound these these
concepts around a single term alright
and that and that is actually I do
actually do robots - I'm just talking a
lot here but that it's all you lords
robot that's my PhD soon anyway what's
interesting to me about consciousness is
why only part of what we do is
accessible to explicit
description right and I think we
understand that now as I mentioned the
comet Oryx problem you can't be worrying
about all the things all the time but
also I think there's a philosophy that
language evolved in the scope of the
module for playing action sequences and
things like that and then it became the
means by which we negotiate coalition
agreements with others so this is why we
could do things like say okay who cares
that women didn't used to have jobs now
we think it would be more fair if when
we could have jobs right because we've
got a the part of us that used to do
planning we also use it for negotiating
coalition's and that's part of creating
fairness alright
so that's cool and we could use AI to do
that but again doesn't mean necessarily
that has to be seen I'm sorry I forgot
that I left the slide in that that has
to be a moral agent right so what we
experienced family logically it's
consciousness seems to be a point when
we update important models and the time
that we probably appropriate to that is
about is proportional to and certainly
are about that again and all of us who
work in machine learning could imagine
doing this if we have bottlenecks from
machine learning and we allocated to the
problems we're currently working on okay
it's not necessarily about choosing
media actually I don't know why I threw
this slide in because this is a lot
another it's a great paper I really like
it but it's a it's a it's another longer
talk so come ask me to come back to it
if you want but my point is that when we
are conscious when we're able to
describe what we've done we seem to be
in this particular position of updating
our current models right and that the
same thing we can do exactly the same
actions and not remember having done
them in a different kind of context so
it's not just about action selection I
think it's about learning but again I'm
trying to demystify consciousness and
say look that's not the point either the
point is moral agency and moral pation
see and those are things that we're
collectively defining so we're not just
trying to discover whether a EIN
requires that motivation going back to
this remember I mentioned this before
all of this stuff that that that this of
this is what we're doing so for those of
you who didn't raise your hand so this
is sort of what a word vector is you
have you have words these are the words
you're trying to understand what they
mean
and then you just say how often did hat
occur within you know some window maybe
ten words of rock or paper or scholar
and how often did the word obscure
occurred within these words and of
course you do that with two million
other words or something but I can only
draw two dimensions and then you and
then you have vectors that that come
from just these counts so it's a very
simple thing it's like a giant Excel
spreadsheet or something right
and then you just measure the cosine
between these angles is semantics so say
how similar and meaning are these words
right how related are they so that's all
that's going on and this is how you know
search search engines work right that's
what you can type in four words and get
and get a page back and it's not all
that's going on is you guys probably
know better than me but it's it's the
basic underlying technology that first
gets that working for you all right
so and then we for that for that the
science paper we use two different
corpuses we use the stanford one which
is the common crawl because we needed to
get all those names there was like a lot
of relatively low frequency names and
and and we only got this from having
yeah eight hundred forty billion tokens
of which 2.2 million were unique so we
got that from stanford but we also did
the same thing using words effect in
Google News apologies I don't know if
microsoft also has I'm sure you do word
embeddings that you distribute and
corpora it was the same except for that
they didn't have enough african-american
names in the corpus so we couldn't put
this I mean article but anyway the first
thing we did was this test the first
thing these are the this is the first
implicit association test paper the
first one about that you know finding
this way of recording implicit bias and
individuals and they knew this was going
to be really controversial so they tried
with something the first thing they at
least reported about is looking at the
names of flowers and names of insects
and pleasant things and unpleasant
things and they say can can we find out
that there's implicit or implicit
associations at least if you want to
call them biases or not the flowers are
more pleasant than insects and and
inside more unpleasant compared to each
other right and yes you can find that
and yes you can find that with with
corpus linguistics all right and and I
think this got really overlooked
it's basically saying and counting words
it turns viscera right so even if you're
talking about phenomenological
consciousness we sort of have that hate
and so even things like if you a when
will a I become empathetic great well
you know and when the Amazon started
doing recommendation services that was
when it was becoming empathetic it's not
empathy like we have where we've
generalize from the models and ourselves
to figure out what each other is doing
which incidentally is biased because it
makes us more able to understand people
more like ourselves so it's actually one
of the mechanisms by which humans can
distance and I really like Paul Bloom's
book about you know against empathy it's
like empathy should be the foundation of
morality anyway but the point is maybe
we can even do better with AI because it
doesn't it's not generalizing from
itself from an internal model it's it
well or an Intel model based on some
experiences it's it's general I think
from models that we've built of other
people so we can actually go out and
find out people all over the world what
were they doing which ones most like you
and what are you're probably feeling if
you're doing that if the other person
tell us how they felt right so so what
about found on the logical consciousness
what about what is the yeah if we build
something that's so amazingly smart that
it starts suffering like we would and
it's and it just can't tell us like a
person that's in isolation people really
worry about this site alright and this
is weird because we're never gonna build
something and chips and wires they have
the same visual experience as much as
cows do and we eat cows right this is a
lucky cow that's out in the field right
so I yeah so we're obliged stability i
we aren't obliged to and that was the
thing that i first started writing about
in the paper see flashes start reading
back in 2007 alright so i think what
actually matters is that AI a is already
super human and i'm sorry i spent so
long on this stuff I didn't think
matters but that is the stuff I usually
ask questions about so but I think
really matters since we already have
super human AI and people like oh but
it's not doesn't learn generally like
humans do wrong are the thing about the
pigeons we have all the stuff that we're
set up culturally and biologically to
learn quickly and what a surprise we can
learn it quickly alright but there's no
more general purpose learning than Bayes
rule I mean come on
you know that so so yeah a nice already
superhuman and there and but people
aren't recognizing it as being so and
then we get into all these kinds of
hazards so like the economic hazard I
mentioned this before I just want to
talk about where does this come from why
are we having these searching inequality
I think part of the problem well this is
again this is we have a paper the next
slide right we have paper can write
about this but we think what's going on
is when you introduce a technology that
reduces the cost of distance then you're
just going to have fewer winners so in
the late 19th century that was like rail
it was telegraph so the newspapers were
getting this and oil right oil was
lighter and cheaper so that's not that I
eliminated the cost of distance but
massively reduced it so if we're gonna
go say we were gonna go for beer after
this right and say we were actually in a
town not on a campus we wouldn't go to
the best pub in the entire town we would
go to some combination of a good pub and
one that's near to us right so that's
one of the ways you can have lots of
pubs and lots of people can get money
right but with all the sudden you can
get your newspaper across the entire
country
then there's fewer newspapers right
because everybody wants to go get the
New York Times or whatever right
not my favorite newspaper and so
whatever so when when the great cop Lane
happens you know some people say
although there was just a war that's
just a war no it's not just a war as I
mentioned it's before the war it was a
massive shift in spending right the war
was part of that the war effort was part
of that but it continued beyond that
into through the Cold War a shift in
Spain that was redistribution maybe it
was when we were giving incredibly high
amounts of wages to uneducated white
males right but somehow we were getting
money out into the into the economy and
and we were getting less inequality all
right literally in 1945 I mean so in
night that this is FDR right so after
one World War and the financial crash of
28 there was a coalition between the
elite and the proletariat in the in the
Democrat Party in America and that was
the New Deal and that was massive
redistribution at the end of 1940
five the globally were sitting around in
Europe agreeing that there were no
longer be wealth extraction and wealth
the the and the banking laws by which
national wealth extraction occurred were
eliminated for about twenty years and
then we innovated right because they
figured out that the countries in Europe
that found into fascism were the ones
that had the highest you know the
inequality that the wealth was being
extracted because they sort of
arbitrarily been part of the set that
had lost the first world war
alright so we need to get everybody to
realize that that that if we that we
want to get more into this area not that
the 60s and 70s were completely smooth
either but it wasn't like a world war
one right so empirically it turns out
their deal Gini coefficients around
point two seven and we're not talking
about completed Galit arianism here
we're not saying like socialism a is the
same of everything you do want to get
more money to people they're doing good
work right we're just talking about how
how much how steep is the is the the
inequality okay so this is actually
people to go into archive within the
last week again I'm not going to talk
about it too much but I was just on
slide but we started from the assumption
that there's as I mentioned it this big
question why is inequality and political
polarization correlated so what we
assumed in the model is that Ingrid
cooperation is less likely to pay off
well but also less likely to fail all
right and so what we showed was that if
if the if the economy is getting worse
it makes sense after a certain point to
reduce your that to give up the
opportunity of having an expected higher
expected outcome in order to make sure
that you have at least enough outcomes
so that you maintain your solvency okay
so the trick here is that you know you
can't have a society without the
individuals being able to survive right
so you can only ask the individuals to
give so much to society
however the interesting thing is that if
the economy keeps getting even worse so
that you can't be solvent just by doing
that in group cooperation then you need
to actually desperately do something and
going to
working with the out-group works makes
sense again so yeah so that that's
that's this bit down here finally and
and then again in some context and I'd
really don't want to go into this too
much before we get through peer review
but we've shown this in a couple of
models that polarization it's much
easier to get gradual increase in to get
gradual decrease again because that
non-linearity at that one point and so
that might explain why you don't tend to
see you tend to see these big
Corrections like the the New Deal rather
than yes I'd like everything just does
slowly relaxing again anyway I already
mentioned the legal one the assigning
responsibility or personhood to
artifacts or trying to tax them I'm
sorry I know Bill Gates thought we
should tax robots robots are not
countable they're not like people if you
set up a tax regime on on the individual
robots then we're just going to
reprogram and redesign the robot so we
all know that right so that's why I'm
actually one of the people that supports
our redistribution based on the shift in
the amount of money a company's worth
from one company one year to the next I
mean actually I didn't put the slide in
so I'll just this relatively quickly I
don't believe that there are that that
we're having free internet interactions
I think that we're bartering data so we
get data or entertainment because we
like going on the internet companies get
information about us from that exchange
right that that not only is that not
because it's not denominated it's not
taxed so income tax is not working right
there but it can't even be dominated
it's often years later that she suddenly
finds a new value in the old data right
so it doesn't make sense
income tax is not making sense right now
in the in the context of what of
Internet services and so that's why I
think we have to go back to thinking
about wealth tax which incidentally is a
lot easier so they have a nice stable
regulation of wealth taxes of income tax
income tax makes all kinds of problems
so I think we really need to think about
major shifts but anyway this is just
talking about the in Europe they are
talking about a person hood for two
reasons partly because there's people
who want to make AI that will be there
there are friends and lovers that they
own right and theirs and theirs and so
those little guys that will go on
television but then quietly there's
things like car companies that are
worried about their creating driverless
cars and how the liability is going to
work when Google and Apple are saying Oh
we'll be liable well of course we'll
take all the liability on and they have
more money than they can legally spend
so if you're like a car company that's
been you know that's been paying
pensions and everything for four decades
then that sounds scary and but but
making them into legal persons so that
you can say hey company I have an idea
why don't you fully automate part of
your business process and then will
allow you to cap your tax and legal
liabilities by whatever you pushed off
into the robot you know this is why I
first got into not first but why I got
increased into ramped up in 2007 was
when people started talking about
ethical robots in battle and I didn't
want people to push the command
decisions on to a robot say oh bad robot
right but now I'm thinking about this in
terms of legal liability so anyway the
European Parliament asked the European
Commission some a to seriously consider
making laws a V personhood so that's why
we watched this paper out we really
dropped all our other projects and got
this paper out to combat that and it
turned out the the yeah at the
Commission the Commission is obliged to
take seriously thing the Parliament
tells it so the U is sort of a democracy
but they shut this thing down in like
four months but anyway there are still
people talking about it for example
Estonia and if it's Tolia makes legal
personhood for any artifact all legal
persons in Europe have to be recognised
by all of Europe so that's a problem so
yeah we already have this problem
there's already shell organizations
which some people if you're into the
philosophy might want to read listen
petite talk about companies as as AI
already so yeah my personal nightmare in
this slide again is from before she both
decided to spend 30 billion something
dollar a year or something on building
AI and also became president for life
but yeah this is a concern that people
so don't want to die that they either
they will believe that this chat bot
that was trained on their email is
themselves yeah or even if they don't
believe it they just liked the idea of
extending their will as we do already
with legal wills about like how this
land can be used sir or my wife will
lose all her her wealth if she remarries
you know things like that right so
people are already trying to extend
their will after after they die I really
worry about people doing this with with
data trusts or something anyway so
closer to home in in sovereign debt
development you know and and I used to
be really angry at several developers at
Microsoft that were coming to policy
events and saying you can't held us
accountable because that would mean we
can't use deep learning and you lose the
magic juice right but that I'll change
that changed sort of midway in 2017
everybody got on message about
accountability and transparency being
fundamental and human centeredness being
fundamental values and I think Microsoft
is absolutely being the biggest adult in
the room right now about that something
very very clear about this but anyway in
the worst case the highest is
inscrutable humans we don't know what
the weights are doing in human brains
either but we still audit companies
I hate we don't look at the accountants
and asses and you could disagree you
could say but but with at least was an
accountant we can put them on the stand
we just saw that right an accountant
goes on the stand and says I absolutely
believe that the amount of work knew
that what Gates told me to do or
something right so you can't still talk
to someone but again we're really just
guessing whether we believe that person
or not in technology we can actually do
better right we the stuff we're doing is
facilitating you know mandating
transparently honest accounting
mechanisms so we could be doing things
like keeping our software revision logs
on I'm good or whatever we could or at
least in-house and be able to show what
we changed why we changed it when did we
train what what what library did we
train our system on
what order did we do it in right we have
the black boxes I mean there hasn't been
this is great there hasn't been a fatal
car accident in autonomous driving that
we haven't found out exactly what
happened you know within a few days that
we knew what the let the robot saw and
what the robot did we may not have it
may take longer to find out why it did
that
but we we have incredible accounts
unlike when humans hit people right
so the that so where are we going with
that yeah so so we can keep that stuff
and we can and that can be easy and
that's a standard because the car
industry has tons of liability and
they're very good at this but the rest
of our software industry could do this
too
right which we had to prove to diligence
right and and I they this is what people
have done with already with AI in in in
Germany there was a car case where
somebody had a stroke I don't want to go
through this is a long story I asked if
you wanted in Q&A but the point was the
car company is able to show that that
there was no way they could have told
the person who had a stroke it was just
you know it was just incredibly bad luck
but how many how much of the software
industry could do that if something went
wrong with AI that they could prove that
they've done everything that it could
possibly have done that was the state of
the expectations right and there's no
reason so I think it you know we need to
know which code we links to I'm really
aesthetics right we don't and and hence
which data we trained with and where
that data data it's provenances right we
can do that all right oh yeah I just
felt obliged to say that actually
transparency is what we work on in bath
it's for real-time domestic systems like
game characters and little robots see
this is because we don't have enough
money we had to build this thing by hand
but this was just this is the priorities
of the system so the system has
hierarchical priorities it's basically
behavior trees just came out of my PhD
but it was the and you can see we're in
the lining up in real-time what it's
doing and when we when we expose not
quite this much to this this much detail
adjust usually at top level the
priorities to the
- - people even ordinary users get
better what's really going on with the
robot it's it's great and one of the
things we're looking at now is if we get
these robots to work at all they won't
give us the new version of Android it's
like three weeks it's like three years
behind Android but once we get the
rights to work we're gonna see whether
that actually the human the human format
interferes with people's ability to
understand cuz we do have a little money
now but meanwhile my a student couldn't
wait Ksenia graduate just graduated so
he put a little bee costume on that
robot and that already changed how
people responded to the transparency
information so anyway active research
was my students right now buddy I mean
back to moral you guys know this right
do I need to explain what happened with
with with Cambridge analytical I assume
everybody's heard about this at this
point but the and this is something that
unites my two countries but yeah
and and it doesn't matter it's just
politics well it matters right I mean
this matters that this is about this is
the scariest thing I actually read in
2017 which is really saying something
all right
and and I'm gonna go ahead and try this
on time ago yeah let's see we have an
army of digital soldiers what we are now
what we call I call them because this
was an insurgency folks this was run
like an insurgency this was irregular
warfare at its finest
in politics and that that story will
will continue to be told here but we
have what we call citizen journalists
yeah because they because so I think
this stuff matters that's right yeah
so if I think it's really essential and
this is something telling people that
are in government that we hold people to
the standards of you you can you can't
magically know how people are going to
use your software but you can say that
there's standards that most people in
that system said you know for example oh
we won't let you see the personal data
of our that we've collected but if you
tell us you know you maybe I'll give
advertisements to a person like a kind
of person you're looking for but we're
not going to just give you their data
and then other people say yeah I sure
here have their data right and if you
can show that like 80 percent of people
knew that was wrong and 20 percent of
people did it eh okay well those 20
percent should be held account and I and
I don't you know despite the obvious
reference here I don't know for sure and
I and I and I trust the courts of law to
do this but if they find that something
is wrong I hope they get really hammered
and I'm not saying eliminate but there's
a lot of hammering that could be done
and could still be afforded I mentioned
this earlier the slide you might
recognize I did the second site half of
that slide is for the automatic kind of
bias one thing you can do is compensate
with design if that's what humans are
right like I said explicit versus
implicit memory right so so you just
know that to express whole idea
ignorance though and this is why I threw
this slide in that's because look at the
conversation we had earlier diversify
test and iterate and improve that's the
thing when we when something comes out
of vignettes we can fix it we can
improve it and that's great yeah so and
then and then the only way to handle
deliveries by audits and regulation so
we've got to expose our stuff out to
help people be able to prove that stuff
okay and so this is it the last slide I
know you guys are dying for that by now
ICT systems heads of science right and
have architecture right and architects
as undergraduates learning about laws
they learn about policy they got and get
license they learn how to work with
governments and urban planners because
at something in the past we get cited
that you know it used to be any rich
person could build a building and
sometimes have fell on people or they
stuck it somewhere and it clogged up
traffic right we don't accept that
anymore and I just think we've gotten to
this stage now we we as computer
scientists have matured what we're
building is our falling over on people
and affecting everyone I hate so we need
to start teaching our undergraduates how
to work with government and we need to
we need to be quiet
right through government in order to
make the world stable enough that we can
flourish right the rate of successful
sustainable innovations what matters not
just the speeds market alright so thank
you I'm sorry that ran a little longer
than I meant believe it or not they're
still trying this maybe I'll start with
one um your highness lie I'm gonna
probably gonna be making mistakes no
please you you had a kind of definition
for moral behavior that was talking
about selecting actions that optimize
the societal benefits or societal value
yeah do you kind of see this as a
prescriptive way of coding up AI agents
like you know this is this is such a
cool question and I have another one
hour long talk about this question
because with humans even one of the
things is what I talked about but that's
why I talked about you know right there
that is it said that a society considers
an action to be moral when it does the
thing that society's decided that it
wants okay but so I was doing something
for about a decade before now yeah I
started in about 2008 working on
understand why there's cultural
variation public goods investment why
because that stuff I told you guys
before about culture being a public good
right so I was trying to understand why
only one species has language I was
working public goods and then actually
the US military asked me to work on
cultural variations I put these two
things together it turns out that
different people treat people that
invest in the public different regions
in the world have people who tend to
treat people differently that invest in
the public good and some of them
actually punished those who give more
than they do to the public good right if
they're allowed to right is this is all
secret you know like a lot of
experiments right so they can figure out
a sneaky way like vandalism or something
right to punish the people who've been
giving the public good they will and
actually you have more tendency to do
that in places that have lower rule of
law and lower GDP and unfortunately
those are two correlated things too
that the economy is always complicated
like that so the point is that you have
to take care of yourself there's
actually an expression in Eastern Europe
in the Slavic languages that if you
don't steal you steal from your family
okay so you had there there's so there's
a there's a baseline of making sure that
you stay alive and that you need to be
able to do individual investment and so
I think part of what society tends to do
is try to get to invest in society and
so our culture tends to do that and so
it's probably slightly overshooting the
level at which you should be investing
in the social level so to give an
immediate example in AI when Google had
their driverless cars going around in
Mountain View that they had the you know
there's strict rules of the road about
what you're supposed to do at a four-way
stop and the Google cars were never
getting to go and they had to build into
it what people always do which is that
they do at some point you take the
initiative you don't wait til every
other car has come to a full stop and
then go right you have to say okay I've
been here long enough and start going
right
so so the I don't think we necessarily
have to build all AI up to the to the
the paragon of ideal morality but I do
think we need to in fact I think you
necessarily have to have two equilibria
that a little bit more and that's one of
the weird interesting things that all
this is going to bring out we actually
are this goes this interacts badly
accountability interacts badly with
privacy right so but I think it's a
fixable problem I'm just saying that
it's something we have to defend but I
think we are going to become much more
explicitly aware of a lot of the things
we had previously not been aware of
because again explicitly we were doing
things we're being encouraged to do
things sort of some sets unnatural but
you're not to be good and useful does
that answer the question which is that
kind of assumes that there is a common
understanding of what's socially good is
and you know it's I'm sure you thought
about that IKEA there could be cases
where some solution could be better for
the majority and there could be another
solution that is worse for the majority
but definitely significantly better for
the minority and this is really real
with all of the perceptive systems where
people talk about like trading off
percentage inaccuracy for some fairness
creatures all right so yeah what this
means and this is I actually wrote a
pay-for about this line is that I still
a PhD student to that the closer AI gets
to human intelligence the more what
we're talking about you know that is
fundamentally what political science has
talked about when they talk about
democracy defending the rights of the
minority right so so and we just leave
it was half of us drop out of
undergraduate or whatever employ blindly
go in and do a lot of programming and
not realizing there's entire disciplines
they're working on these problems so now
we are Society right we have to deal
with all those problems the defending
the rights of the minority and and the
fact that these you know that there
isn't a particular absolute correct
solution that solutions may be different
in different contexts that's the kind of
complexity that law and and politics
have had to deal with for millennia yeah
absolutely
biggest question but they're with me or
good the world agent be such without
being borrow society how can you be
wrong agent without being part of that
society okay so thank you first of all
we need to just confirm these two terms
so there's an agent being morale taking
those moral actions and there's the
moral agent as I just described which is
the thing that's being called
accountable for its actions and you can
you be a moral agent I don't think for
either of those two definitions actually
you can be without in society because
the society is one that's declaring the
rules that the person being moral is
following and the for the moral agent
that's being defined by the society
there's that it's basically the set of
responsible actors so obviously the
societies that defines it so for both of
those I think you need a society to get
the definitions for the morality I don't
think that morality exists in the vacuum
but that's okay because you're not going
to getting intelligence than vacuum
either the microbial will totally take
it out that all all of us every all all
of us intelligent calculus species we
all have social you know if nothing else
we come from parents we're all the
products of sections of sexual
reproduction so yeah I'm really curious
about your last piece so what are what
are some like the government regulations
that you proceeded and what would you
recommend for like well the main thing
that we're trying to do in the UK at
least which is where I'm most I've been
an academic since 2002 so I mean I've
been an adult since I didn't know length
I but basically I've been a professional
in this particular discipline since 2002
so I'm just more familiar in in within
Britain but at least in Britain we we
don't feel like we need a lot of new
laws we just need to start applying them
into tech into ICT and into software
which is something we hadn't been doing
before because people didn't understand
it and so I think the main thing is if
we maintain the current standards of
accountability then that will encourage
so if I should say we thought if the
government with which I do feel we're
all part of if the government part of us
maintains accountability through through
into the software industry and starts
understanding it and actually macaque
gave a great review and wired
interviewing wired about this but yes of
course we always watch a new industry
for a while for a few decades and then
we get involved but anyway so if they
start pursuing accountability then we
the other part of we the software
industry are going to be highly
motivated to be able to have
transparency at least sufficient
transparency so that we can prove that
we've done due diligence right so that
because you're not going to have perfect
transparency I already said this to one
of you I think of you today but there's
this thing called the map of Germany
problem and I've no idea why it's
Germany
the point is that a map of Germany that
was perfect that every detail would be
the same size as Germany it would be no
use this is actually another reframing
of the whole box thing about all models
are use Iran but some are useful right
so you you only you there is of course a
trade-off about how much transparency
can have how much explain ability you
can have those kinds of things but we
can motivate companies to make the
trade-off themselves internally rather
than mandating the amount of
transparency by just maintaining
accountability and accountability is
actually already in the law it just
hasn't been pursued into the technology
companies before and now the
government's are realized in technology
companies matter so maybe they will just
start pursuing it
so what we're trying to say is we're
trying to say is that we don't really
need so much some new laws as I mean we
need a new practice and to just a better
education and in the in the in the in
the prosecutors offices and actually
again talking to the people I've only
thought to three people so far name
traffic names but they sound like
Microsoft has already sort of realizing
this as a big corporate entity you can
you can cast in the positive way which
is that you want the software to be
doing what's best for society or you can
also say that you want to evade big
corporate liability yes right that's
those those come for free together
there's this interesting let's go to the
page I like to hear your thoughts is the
opinion or the school of thought that
says let's create artificial
intelligence and the school of the DA
says no the suppose Erin Lestrade
assistive intelligence that's something
that is always partnering with the human
is doesn't have independent behaviors
always at the service of a second
prosthesis if I'm a human what do you
think think should go if you have a
choice right okay so I think that yeah
it's a great question I'm glad you asked
it it's it's you're not quite using the
language I presented here but that's
okay
because you're using for artificial
intelligence what I briefly mentioned a
lot of people are using for artificial
general intelligence by which they mean
all kinds of contradictory things
because not a coherent theme and I was
mostly talking about the other mission
AGI but you're talking about the
human-like AGI that there's something
that's really is human conscious and all
those other kinds of things so my so a
lot of this was about that and it didn't
come together so now I have a chance to
bring it together so that's great thank
you very much for your question the
point is that we can't create a
something out of silicon that is a part
that is an agent in our society as it's
currently run because the sanctions that
we do to keep each other from doing the
wrong things aren't going to work on a
machine right machines are not going to
have I mean you could build into a robot
you know a bomb and a timer and the
timer is set when there's no other
person in the room and the bomb is gonna
go off if there's no person around for
five minutes okay and you can say well
that's kind of like humans that they
don't like to be isolated because but
it's not not not liking to be isolated
to know that you're just going to blow
up right what's your investment not
being blown up and in humans and fish
and everything else there's a systemic
stress right and and if we have well
designed AI that we can be responsible
and accountable for and all those things
you're not gonna have things like
systemic stress you can have modularity
and you're gonna have ways of knowing
you know there's gonna be more separable
so I don't think there's a safe way to
build a system but basically I think
there's no way that we can build a
system that we would regulate like we
regulate other people and and that's you
know that was why I just said I think
even legal personhood has been
overextended right now that which is why
we're having this problem to the shell
corporation so I was people building
buildings deliberately to make them go
bankrupt so they can launder money right
you know so that so that's the kind of
thing that I think that we see when
we're going out and building these other
these other people I mean I understand I
wanted to do it too you know it's why do
you think I got into AI I understand the
desire to procreate that's a very
fundamental part of life that we have a
desire to procreate but I think it's
better than
I mean there's a lot of things you can
want that aren't necessarily good things
for you hey and and I think it's one of
those things that that it's better for
us to figure out how to procreate in
terms of making humans at the core as
more as the things that are the
responsibility or the sources of the
creativity right so you can you can
project your your legacy in other ways
you know through your writings or even
through your AI chatbot thing right but
it's but but you don't make that the
legal person or the or the moral person
that is or the more patients are in this
case that's competing with your
biological legacy I don't see that's
coherent now I understand that people
think like well Humanity is only gonna
be around for four billion years because
that's how long the Sun is going to last
you know but actually there's been no
hominids they've lasted more than a
couple million years as a species I mean
and but even with technology there's
like how many you know software formats
or data formats have have been around
for 80 years right you know humans made
it make it for 80 years and yet we think
that AI is going to extend ourselves
this is this mathematical fallacy I
thought it's like before we you know
it's not math it's not gonna be perfect
an eternal so I think that we're not
going to we're never like it that was
the cow slide we're never gonna
reproduce something that's going to have
the same the phenomenal allergies we
have or even as much of you know I could
have set a fruit fly level on a cow at
another mammal right but we can build
things that say don't kill shut me off
or whatever but I'd rather and this is
my earliest works if you look at my
earliest works it's just like just build
in the backup you know even if your best
friend does turn out to be a robot and
somehow you have some way of freeing and
you don't have to
you should still if you're in a fire you
uh you you you save the the Shakespeare
well it's probably backed up too so you
can shave you can save a toddler or
something leave your best friend there
and your best friend comes walking up
and hands you the new bill for its new
body right it's it's not a problem so I
think we we need to understand and that
and I think again this is bleed or not
there were a lot of slides cut
that we have to understand that it's
okay that our that that our society is
is based around the fact that we're a
bunch of apes and that our morality and
our entire social intuitions and all
those things are shared with a lot of
other chimpanzees right and you're not
going to have something that has the
same motivations whether social or or or
ambitions or whatever that chimpanzees
have that you build out I mean you could
sort of absorb it from like I said from
art from our text all right so you could
probably get it a blueprint that way but
it's not going to be empathically from
the inside motivated the same way so I
think it's a mistake to lead people down
that direction because they do want it
so badly you know you said this is gonna
be the last question I thought oh
there's seven minutes left that's not
true but my answer just took eight six
minutes there's only one minute left
[Applause]